[Applaudissements]
l'être humain vit avec le temps le
danseur et chorégraphe que je suis aussi
mais différemment
je compte avec des 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 et
je vous invite à partager une petite
chorégraphie avec moi de quatre temps
attention depuis votre siège il ya aucun
risque
juste avec les mains je vous donne
l'exemple en fait le 1 c'est saisir une
opportunité un bon moment le 2 et le 3
créativité débrouillardise c'est le
brouillard était perdu et leucate une
conclusion qui n'est pas définitive
c'est parti on s'accompagne 1 ont saisi
quelque chose 2 vous êtes libre de faire
ce que vous voulez une grimace à votre
voisin un chèque ce que vous voulez 2 3
4 une conclusion pas définitive rens
fin juin des années 2000 je connais que
le chemin de mon école et mon quartier
devancé le parking et mon hlm c'est le
parking derrière le terrain d'herbe et
il ya la fête de quartier la fête de
quartier
c'est plein de culture plein d'odeurs
plein de personnes
un barbecue est plein de talent ou pas
qui monte sur scène et j'ai découvert
une prestation de break dance et
révélations je jette ma balle de basket
je cours derrière mon bâtiment côté
herbe première roulades première tâche
d'herbe première embrouille avec ma mère
et bizarrement je me fais piquer par la
chose pendant trois ans jusqu'à 2003
selon ses calculs et 7 côté herbe bien
devient la salle d'entraînement pendant
trois ans je suis à l'affût du moindre
mouvement à l'époque y avait pas
internet donc cassette magnétoscope
je m'amuse enregistrer toutes les nuits
d
clip en espérant d'avoir un petit
mouvement dans une vidéo juste ils
disent aussi la technique du scotch sur
les cassettes pour enregistrer la radio
voici vous connaissez pour écouter
écouter de la musique pouvoir
m'entraîner dessus dans ma chambre à la
radio j'entends un spot publicitaire
les championnats de france de break
dance se déroule à montpellier les
meilleures équipes se rencontrent et une
équipe ira représenter la france aux
championnats du monde en allemagne
j'étais avec un ami on se regarde ça
fait ça on s'est compris il est plus il
est plus âgé que moi et il m'a dit jamel
debbouze jeu s'occupe de tout tu sais
que je dois rien on a fait stratégie
meilleure copine pour sortir en boîte tu
dis tu dors chez moi je dis que je dors
chez toi c'est parti je prends mon sac à
dos un sac de madeleine je dis pas la
marque et je me rends à la gare j'arrive
à la gare je suis perdu mais je
comprends tout les destinations ya plein
de personnes qui passent avec les
bagages etc vous est mon ami il est pas
là alors je suis bête
il m'attend sur le quai je me rends sur
le quai et mon ami n'est pas là
j'entends une petite voix qui dit
racisme reims le train à destination de
montpellier vient bientôt partir et j'ai
décidé de 1 les secours on monte dans le
train
2 c'était freestyle bizarrement j'avais
pas de conversation et de communication
avec les personnes âgées il ya une grand
mère qui me dit oh là là ça se voit le
tap authentique et les contrôleurs vont
passer les contrôleurs vont passer ils
vont te mettre une amende je t'invite à
te cacher derrière mes bagages au
3 ok mais c'était pas derrière les
bagages là c'était au dessus et je les
fais contorsions 4 j'arrive à
montpellier une conclusion pas
définitive je sors de la gare soleil un
gros panneau publicitaire les
championnats de france de breakdance
samedi alors on a l'habitude d'être en
avance ou en retard les shows rivés
mercredi
vous comprenez pourquoi mon pote tu
étais pas là la gare je décide à
montpellier 2-1 ont saisi l'opportunité
il ya le soleil on va à la plage comment
je sais plus 2 je me balade je mange des
madeleines et je décide de me faire un
petit confort avec plein de serviettes
en location longue durée sur les balcons
et je me suis je me fais un confort pour
la jeudi pour la nuit du jeudi et la
nuit du vendredi pour une conclusion pas
définitive en fête samedi
la plage est devenue une salle
d'entraînement tous les danseurs de
france profitent de la journée pour
profiter du soleil de la plage pour
aller en soirée au championnat alors je
crée des affinités avec des danseurs qui
ne viennent de lyon supporter la ville
de lyon et ils disent oui tu es avec
nous on va la place de la comédie
let's go je me suis vu offrir un fast
food et je vous dis c'était très très
dur il y avait plus de madeleine et
place de la comédie ya plein de cercle
certes des danseurs alors je vous
explique un danseur fonctionne avec des
questions réponses pour s'affronter
j'arrive je fais un mouvement qu'est ce
que tu peux répondre de mieux ou pas et
je m'assois dans un cercle
mes amis de lyon de cette journée se
lève et danses etc et tout d'un coup il
ya huit personnes qui rentrent 9 bien
habillé beau gosse bien qu'au fait
bronzer en fait c'est les danseurs de
montpellier et viennent défendre leur
ville c'est leur territoire
et dans les questions réponses mais en
fait ils prennent le dessus sur les
personnes avec qui j'avais créé des
affinités de lyon et je viens d'un
milieu où la loyauté est dur et je me
dis je me lève et j'entends qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent campagnard alors je viens
de reims
j'ai passé trois jours à la plage
j'étais rouge écrevisse sauf que voilà
il se reconnaît sauf que il ya un petit
truc en fait qu'il fallait pas que je
fasse c'était prendre la casquette et la
met à l'envers super pouvoirs petit
flashback avec aucune information dans
mon quartier je pensais que ailleurs
c'était plus fort je pensais que les
américains ils étaient des monstres
je pensais que à paris il était ultra
stylée donc je m'entraînais derrière mon
bâtiment dix fois plus que et je me suis
vu arriver à avoir un niveau français
bat au top
donc j'ai mis une petite correction si
on regarde cette aide est
et voilà donc ça finit le lendemain le
soir même bizarrement je suis en train
de soutenir la ville de lyon et ils
gagnent les championnats de france
mon ami me dit on remonte à lyon tu
viens avec nous oui j'arrive à lyon je
décide d'appeler ma mère allô maman
en fait je pense que je faisais france à
montbard à l'afp ne pas être même dans
l'appareil photo
je crois qu'on l'a fait très fortes
amendes voire mandat cash j'ai mon
billet je rentre à reims est en fait
pendant le festival la des championnats
de france il y avait des petits stands
avec des sites internet
alors moi je suis piquée j'ai retenu je
voulais savoir les informations
maintenant je vais aller chercher les
informations mais il n'y a pas internet
où tu as les informations sur internet
quand tu viens d'un quartier la mjc je
vais aller me j c je me pose je rentre
tout est à ta ta ta plein de topic
et il y en a une qui pique on recherche
il se mêle de marseille avec une vidéo
truc de fou j'essaie de cliquer ça
marche pas il faut un mail eux
attendez ce n'est pas fini je vais voir
l'animateur oui il me faut un mail etc
il fait un mail et ou avec un nom
bizarre et en fait c'était une adresse
caramail
elle m'a servi pour chat et je rentre je
me crée un profil est en fait je vais
cliquer et puis on voit la vidéo quand
je mets une petite rouste hogan
montpellier et je dis à tout le monde ou
un regard regardez c'est moi c'est moi
c'est moi ouais mais non c'est pas toi
s'écrit marseille ah ouais je réponds
non je suis bien de reims etc
donc je recrée un lien avec des
personnes de lyon et avec l'affinité
affinités affinités je me retrouve un
mois d'août à aller passer tout le mois
d'août à lyon et comment ça se passe
là-bas en fait le groupe originaire de
lyon qui gagnent les championnats de
france sont soutenues par la ville au
lieu de s'entraîner dehors ils ont accès
à la salle du ballet à l'opéra de lyon
la classe sauf que c'était eux c'était
pas moi et moi j'attendais en bas et je
m'entraîne et je m'entraîne et je
m'entraînais y redescendre et on partait
manger un kebab
le lendemain on s'entraînait en bas
c'était leur entraînement y monter moi
j'attendais en bas pendant deux heures
et redescendez on allait manger un kebab
le lendemain on s'entraîne en bas il
monte et redescend avant il me dit
ismael tu montes tous les danseurs j'ai
commencé à y montre je monte ou direct
il était en ligne m'ont dit oui ce mail
ou en fait
ok tu écoutes côté performance mais tous
les jours qu'on passe ensemble en fait
c'est pareil que nous on veut que tu
fasses les championnats du monde avec
nous je bégaie your way je rentre chez
moi et on est en septembre
c'est l'école je fais une semaine
d'école le week-end à lyon répétition
une semelle d'école lucquin à lyon avec
des billets de train payer et on arrive
au moment où on doit partir de lyon pour
aller en allemagne
encore un train de nuit très très longue
douche très longue encore long de ouf et
on arrive en allemagne à braunschweig
pour ceux qui connaissent et 0 blague
gros coup de pression on arrive à
l'auberge de jeunesse et je comprends
que la saison n'est pas là pour blaguer
sur chaque porte
il ya un drapeau de chaque pays amérique
au japon en afrique du sud
et les championnats du monde c'est plus
de 30 pays où on présente quelque chose
un show un spectacle et à la fin les
jury décide de quatre pays pour faire la
troisième et la quatrième place est la
première et la deuxième place c'est tout
alors je me rappelle pas de troisième et
quatrième places je sais qu'il y avait
le japon et je me rappelle plus trop et
philippe et on entend la corée est
contre la france hu
une bouteille de pepsi pendant 20
minutes questions réponses et je vous
dis les asiatiques c'est des machines de
guerre
franchement en souplesse ont tous
franchement c'était des monstres mais on
fait notre travail
les jury délibère et choisissent le le
gagnant mais avant de dire le gagnant
c'est comme dans tout il choisit d'un
décompte 10 mai sauf que c'est en
anglais on est en allemagne peine nine
hype seven 6 viive stop
et puis en fait ben en fait je suis
devenu quelqu'un à ce moment là et puis
c'est relou parce que tout à l'heure à
la répète ça fait pareil mais la star
non mais ça fait pas et à la répète donc
à 4 en fait tout s'est inversé le est
devenu 1,4 j'ai vu monter dans le train
je me suis vu avec cette dame âgée
merci je me suis vu contorsionniste sur
la plage les madeleines pour arriver à
france championne du monde
[Applaudissements]
je vais rester comme ça
en résumé tout s'articule sur quatre
temps je pense dans la vie saisir le bon
moment
2 et 3 débrouillardise créativité 4 une
conclusion pas définitive et pour ma
part et je vous le souhaite de accrocher
le bon moment monter dans votre train de
vos objectifs que ce soit personnel ou
passeport famille et cetera d'amour ou
autres freestylers chercher galéré
avancé perdez-vous pour arriver à une
conclusion qui est pas définitive pour
finaliser ici
[Applaudissements]